[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We're going to take a
look at how Cloud Code makes it
easy to develop for Kubernetes.
To develop for
Kubernetes, you need
to set up Kubernetes
configuration for your project,
find how to efficiently iterate
on your code on Kubernetes,
and learn how to perform
common development tasks
on Kubernetes, like debugging.
But it can be
challenging to master
all the necessary config, slow
and error-prone to perform
the repetitive tasks of
building, pushing and deploying
images, and difficult to set up
debugging against a Kubernetes
cluster.
That's why we built Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is a set
of development tools
for Google Cloud that
includes IDE extensions
for Visual Studio Code,
and JetBrains IDEs,
such as intelliJ.
Cloud Code helps you
author Kubernetes
config with completions,
linting, inline documentation,
and code snippets.
It automates the process
of running and updating
your code on Kubernetes
and so much more,
that we don't have time to
talk about it all today.
To get started with
Cloud Code, download it
from your favorite IDE's
extension marketplace.
Let's take a look at Cloud
Code for VS CODE in action.
We'll get started by using Cloud
Code to create a new Kubernetes
Project.
Cloud Code also works with your
existing applications, as well.
First, select the Cloud
Code menu from the task bar
and select New Application.
Next, choose the language
and template you want to use.
I'll choose Node js hello world.
Finally, name your project
and hit Enter to create it.
Now that our project
has been created,
let's take a look at
a Kubernetes config.
Expand Kubernetes' manifest
and select helloservice.yaml.
Since this is a
starter application,
the yaml's already here for us.
But if it wasn't, you could
use Control-Space to view
the available snippets for
Kubernetes config files
to create your own from scratch.
Here, let's just see
how Cloud Code helps
add a new property to the spec.
I can return to the next line
and use Control-Space again
to see completions for
possible properties.
External traffic policy
looks interesting.
Let's take a look at that.
Cloud Code offers
inline documentation
here and on hover for all
these Kubernetes types.
After accepting
external traffic policy,
let's try setting it to none.
Looks like I didn't read the
documentation well enough.
Cloud Code's linting
is telling me
I need to use cluster or local.
Let's use cluster.
Now that we've seen how Cloud
Code helps manager Kubernetes
in yaml, let's see how it
helps you deploy to Kubernetes.
First, we need a
cluster to deploy to.
Let's move over to
the Cloud Code view.
I went ahead and created
a Google Kubernetes engine
cluster from Cloud Code earlier,
by clicking this button.
But you can add any Kubernetes
cluster, including local ones,
such as Docker or MiniKube.
To deploy, we select Cloud
Code from the task bar
again, and select
Run on Kubernetes.
I'll confirm the cluster
I want to deploy to,
confirm a default image registry
for my Google Cloud project.
And Cloud Code begins
the deployment.
It looks like the deployment
has completed successfully.
So let's take a look by Command
clicking the IP address shown
in the output window.
When we return to Cloud Code,
we see that watch mode is on.
That means I can
make a code change
and it will automatically
be redeployed.
Let's give that a try.
I'll expand the source
folder, select app.js,
and change hello world to
hello devs, and save the file.
We can see that Cloud
Code is automatically
redeploying the service.
And we can return
to the web browser,
refresh, and see
the updated page.
Let's see what it looks
like to debug a Kubernetes
app with Cloud Code.
I'll go to the Run
and debug view.
Select debug on Kubernetes
and click the Play button.
We see in the output, that
the debugger is attached.
So let's set a breakpoint
in the app.js file
and reload the page.
The breakpoint hit, and
we can see all the utility
that we expect
with the debugger,
even with code running
on a Kubernetes cluster.
You just learned
how Cloud Code lets
you focus on writing code
like you always have,
and spend less time learning
an endless set of new tools
and technology just to be
productive on Kubernetes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]